Just in case we need
to help with more party
planning for the king,
let's get ourselves
some practice with
solving systems
of equations with
simple elimination.
And so here's the
exercise right over here.
We have x minus 4y is
equal to negative 18,
and negative x plus
3y is equal to 11.
So let's try to work this out.
I'll get my little
scratch pad out.
This is the exact same problem.
We just rewrite it again.
It never hurts to rewrite
it, get more familiarity
with the problem.
So x minus 4y is
equal to negative 18.
And then we have negative
x plus 3y is equal to 11.
So the thing that
jumps out at my brain--
we want to eliminate
one of the variables.
And we have an x
here, and we have
a negative x right over there.
So that feels like those
would cancel each other out
very well, so let's do that.
Let's add negative x plus
3y to the left-hand side
of x minus 4y.
And then we can add 11
to the right-hand side
because, as the second statement
shows, this is equal to this.
So if we add this to
the left-hand side,
we could add the same thing
to the right-hand side.
But instead, we're just going
to add the 11, because it's
the exact same thing
as negative x plus 3y.
So we're going to add 11
to the right-hand side.
And so let's see what
happens when we do that.
Well, the whole purpose is
that you have an x minus an x.
Those cancel out.
And then you're just left
with negative 4y plus 3y.
Negative 4 of something
plus 3 of something
is you're going to have
negative 1 of that something,
or you could just
say negative y.
And then that's going to
be equal to-- and remember,
we can still say equal
because we're essentially
adding the same thing
to the right-hand side
that we're adding to
the left-hand side.
11 is the same thing
as negative x plus 3y.
11 plus negative
18 is negative 7.
And now we're in
the home stretch.
If we want to solve for y,
we can divide both sides
by negative 1, or multiply
both sides by negative 1,
depending on how
you want to view it.
So let's divide both
sides by a negative 1.
We are left with y is
equal to positive 7.
But we aren't done yet.
We need to figure out
what x is equal to.
So we can take this
value for y, and we
should be able to
substitute it back
into either of these
equations to solve for x.
So let's do that.
Let's use the top equation.
So we have x minus 4 times y,
but now we know that y is 7.
We know that y is
7 at the point that
satisfies both of
these equations.
Why did I write y again?
4 times 7 is equal
to negative 18.
Let's simplify.
You get x minus 28 is
equal to negative 18.
Now to solve for x-- and we've
done this many, many times
before-- we just add
28 to both sides.
So let's add 28 to the
left, 28 to the right.
And we are left with x
is equal to negative 18
plus 28 is the same thing
as 28 minus 18, which is 10.
So we get x is equal to
10 and y is equal to 7.
And what's really
good about this is you
can verify them for yourselves.
If you take this first equation,
10 minus 4 times 7, so 10
minus 28 does indeed
equal negative 18.
So it checks with
the first equation.
Now let's check the
second equation.
Negative x, so negative
10 plus 3 times 7.
What is that equal to?
That's negative 10 plus 21,
which does indeed equal 11.
So it satisfies both of them.
So now let's check our answer
on the little exercise engine.
So we have y is equal
to 7, x is equal to 10.
So we have x is equal to
10 and y is equal to 7.
Check our answer, and
we've got it right.
We're ready to do some more
cupcake planning with the king.